j'étais un sacré bon artiste
illustrateur de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
aujourd'hui j'arrive à peine à écrire
mon nom
j'ai appris ce qui vous était arrivé et
lui sont tombés à 5 de son ca miracle
qu'ils aient survécu
je suis ton traitement j'ai été frappé
et laissé pour mort sans raison un pied
devant l'autre
c'est sa marque ont parfois de la
souffrance
mais j'ai créé un monde où je peux dire
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bienvenue à
marouene c'est mon installation vous
êtes artiste c'est une histoire
compliquée à caen témoin vous tenez
vraiment à savoir
oui ils ont rayé de ma mémoire le
moindre de mes souvenirs
[Musique]
tout ce qui date d'avant l'agression a
disparu donc c'est à mes poupées de
raconter l'histoire ce sont les femmes
de marouene et elle protège marque nous
ne faisons qu'un au lieu des méchants
c'est parti
[Musique]
j'ai cru vous entendent réclamer
l'addition pas l'addition pas l'addition
toutes les poupées de marouene sont des
gens que vous connaissez
ouais il ya ana da da julie et carla là
tu peux pas continuer à fierté problème
robert tard est-ce que tu seras là pour
le jugement tu dois regarder en face les
cons qui t'ont tamas et je sais vraiment
pas comment je vais faire pour notre
souffrance c'est n'être qu'un bureau on
m'a volé la vie que j'avais avant mais
je suis toujours là
j'ai l'espoir
et j'ai ma ville
j'ai mes amis on couvre des arrières je
vais m'en sortir
rien n'est impossible à marouene c'est
votre tournée les filles
marouene est tellement extraordinaire il
faut que les gens de foi à la vie à
l'amour et aux femmes de marouene
[Musique]